hi nancy how are you i'm doing good how
about you
i'm doing very well uh you um you know
my this is a this is a podcast i can see
you
my audience cannot uh and i can tell
right away this is gonna be an
interesting
interview you seem like a fascinating
person to me you're very attractive very
exotic
you have um man there's a lot going on
right now you seem i'm getting a goth
vibe from you is that fair
yes yes okay uh let's let's describe
your goth look a little bit are you into
the goth world
is that your is that your thing yes i
guess you can say that
well tell us a little bit about yourself
uh well i'm 30 years old i
live in chicago i was born and raised
here i
love to travel i love going to haunted
houses
and so much here we go
harry i love how he was like i'm because
i i'm looking at you
and you're all dressed in black and your
hair is jet black and as i said you're
a very attractive person but i'm getting
this strong
aren't you getting sort of a strong
halloween vibe almost yes
and then uh you i i asked you and you're
like well i'm
30 and this and that and it's all very
normal and i
love haunted houses and i'm like okay
that's telling me a lot right there
yeah i i'm gonna say i i know we
don't describe what happens in your room
but there are two
of the creepiest masks i've ever seen
right behind you
yeah hanging on the wall or two in the
clown yeah a monkey mask and a clown
mask and they look like they're from the
1930s or 40s or something and they're
scary as hell
they really are are you are you a
murderer is that what you do
well let's see i've never murdered
anything but i do select that animals
as well oh my god she's you're holding
up right now uh
right now let me describe for the
listener nancy is holding up a jar that
had some kind of a
creature in it what is that creature in
the jar so it's actually a cat
and it is it's a diaper nice specimen
so it is a clear stained and it is
dyed as well and uh it's a gelatinous
cat skeleton and there's been a dye
injected into it and the bones are all
blue
blue and uh tint of pink so
i collect taxidermy i collect wet
specimens along with my husband of
course uh
oh of course yeah couldn't do it without
him
yeah funny how we hear about him but we
don't see him in fact no one's seen him
for years
um oh there he is oh hi husband good to
see you
yeah you as well okay here's my job my
job is to keep you guys talking until
the fbi can show up
we want to thoroughly we want to
thoroughly look through your basement
and um we were wondering why they're
those exotic butterflies everywhere
what what's going on with you guys
you're both uh
you're both you seem like ghouls you
seem like other
worldly ghouls yeah that's fair
uh tell us uh nancy what do you what do
you guys do
for a living what what's your bag man
so uh what we do for a living is we are
actually haunted house reviewers in the
chicagoland area for the scare factor
wait you you review haunted houses
yes okay so it's not enough that other
people can go to a haunted house and
just write a yelp review
you're the real people that say is this
haunted house worth your time or not
pretty much yeah we break it down from
how great how scary
how how well the entertainment is inside
outside customer service we break it
down for you